hello everyone just another quick alana
update at the start of a play watch
listen which we have
happen more often than we should i just
wanted to let everyone know that our
next episode will be live
from 12 30 to 1 30 p.m next tuesday um
that is pacific time tuesday
24th um it'll be my lunch break so it
will be those exact times we cannot go
any longer unfortunately it'll be very
specific to fit me in there
to make it work um but yes we will be
live celebrating our 40th episode and
almost our one year anniversary as well
also i'm aware there's some
lag in this episode uh if you're
watching the video version and the audio
levels are a little bit off um we have a
new person who has technically joined
the team to edit the show
um and is going through the process of
learning the ridiculous kinks that come
with balancing audio
uh it's very difficult and it is not his
fault we just wanted to give you all the
heads up
i seriously consider
driving down to where our
either our mayors not our mayor but our
like our city councilman
specifically for where i live banging on
his door
and passionately not requesting
demanding
both street bumps
and parking signs because people park in
front of our house
and it's because they just want i may be
selling i may be selling maps
yeah why is that that may be on me video
game started
why is people parking in front of your
house a problem
because i i just hate it
i just like it all right that's that's
straight yeah that's fair enough
yeah part of the app
but there'd be people that's like oh
you're just gonna park your car in front
of my street for forever like you just
leave it there
that's true uh and there's also like
our house was built like in a lot of
houses in los angeles for this way too
it's like it's a two-car garage it's
like no it's not because when that house
was built nobody had two cars
um and so like one car fits in there
great
but two cars will not and so i can't fit
my car
in the garage so i have to park like
right in front of our house
so i do that there's nothing worse than
coming home from the one time that i get
out in the week
and someone's parked in front of my
house it's like i gotta i can't parking
from i
i've literally said i can't park in
front of my own house i say that
the other thing is that it's there's
speed bumps
that people come hauling us down our
street and we have a
quiet street but somebody put up on waze
or whatever it's like hey did you know
you could cut around
and go through this really quiet
pedestrian street
and just pretend you're still on the
101.
it's terrible the children and small
animals just
melt on the front end of your bumper
there's only been one time where i was
out in the front yard and i was watering
because traveler loves to play with the
garden hose and i i literally was just
like
i heard someone careening down the
corner and i just went
sloop just let the water hit their
windshield
i like it that was a very big speed bump
controversy i lived in
uh speed bump not street bump yeah
street bump's a different thing
they also actually call themselves speed
humps i love
those stair hubs good stuff but those
only on wednesday
i lived in like a sort of it wasn't a
gated community but effectively the same
thing
um that had like a body corporate and
you would have to pay the body corporate
to like
you know deal with this stuff and there
were some very stupid rules they had to
deal with
pretty much but basically it was just a
board of
of old white men complaining about
things nobody else cared about none of
the residents cared about like you
weren't allowed to park in one of the
parking bays
uh for you you could only have one guest
at a time park in any of the parking
bays but all of the rest in the entire
place would be empty and they'd be like
well we saw two cars and people came to
your house
we'd be like but they're all empty and
they'd be like that's it's against the
rules it doesn't matter like they're
never full
irrelevant you've got to get them out of
there they're not allowed to park in the
parking base the other one
that's too much was that chance yeah it
was it was really bad
the busy body is one of the lowest we
just started calling them nazis would be
like the nazis of the estate
who were just very upset about
everything um
we had a speed bump issue where they
installed
speed bumps that were illegally loud uh
they were not the concrete ones because
those are more expensive they were like
once it like bolted onto the ground
oh yeah and that happened i guess before
the estate nazis started working there
and they held this full meeting that was
like rallying
to make sure that we could get these
concrete speed bumps that nobody really
gave a [ __ ] about because it didn't make
a big difference they were like
where was this in australia it was just
like let me
not ever be you later in life um
i would prefer not to have to worry
about speed bumps but
to be fair in troy's defense when you
live in a quiet neighborhood you got
kids
i understand my favorite is the sign
that says drive like you
tune in and i was like yeah dude just do
that just drive like you live here
and it's we have a lot of kids in our
neighborhood and especially after covid
everyone
it became a little bit more idyllic and
people would
we do more walks that's the main thing
that we do is we just get out and walk
and so when people come hauling ass and
there's not a stop sign so they can just
kind of come around and just
haul ass down the street it's just like
dudes what the
slow down yeah anyway i but i'm i think
we should have the whole
recipe about this actually i really want
i really want a photo of troy
in a in a like a wicker chair in the
lawn with a little speed
little radar yeah exactly
right he's got a little notepad writing
down license plate numbers
and uh eight miles over dear did you see
eight miles eight miles kill somebody
it's true every k over is killa that's
what we say in australia
um hello everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen i feel
weird that we're introducing the show
even this early
do you have coffee right now wrong yeah
yeah yeah okay good
i started to not because we're doing it
later
you've been drinking that for a while
it's like probably like 20 minutes yeah
do you microwave coffee who does that
abomination
thank you thank you austin i although i
realized in a like survival situation i
think the reason why
if it's black coffee it it takes it
better
if it if it takes it better like
like i think the presence of any kind of
half and half or milk or whatever in the
coffee
is what makes the microwaving process
turn it into an abomination
just microwaving my queue no it's it's
still bad but it's more tolerable mike
i'm curious if you've heard about this
thing
that americans think is okay
which is making tea
by boiling water by putting it in a
microwave
once you can't boil water in a microwave
like
americans don't by default have kettles
yes apparently it is odd to have a
kettle i mean of course troy you're
you may as well identify as a european
you don't count
austin do you have a kettle i have a
kettle i don't okay
um i don't actually have i don't use it
that often oh thank god
that's is for right well the thing is i
don't what's the problem
if boiling the water before you add
anything to it
that i don't see why that would be
anything there is ultimately no issue
other than this is weird you guys just
being weird
like in my case i don't have a range or
anything
you know it's electric kettle oil water
i have two christmas presents for you
now
and a toilet seat cover i got you that
and we saw how that worked out
does everybody know with us we're gonna
have to cycle back guys so talk to us
about the toilet seat cover that's the
level of friendship i don't think i've
ever achieved do we know
i don't know does that not come up here
i would buy something
troy bought austin a toilet seat you
don't understand
first of all it was not it was not a as
as much as it sounds like a practical
gift
it was actually a humanitarian effort
on my behalf because
not just for the visitors of his studio
but also to salvage what is
the remnants of his dark soul because
the problem is
lost cause total because austin
began showtime freud has become a very
popular word especially with
you know news of late his specific brand
of that
is hearing the cries
and pleas for help that emitted from his
bathroom
when anyone tried to touch the toilet at
all what because
it was the jankiest toilet seat cover
ever it was basically it was basically a
jenga tower
if you just if you like yeah just
because 99 of the time i'm the only
person around here
uh even under non-coveted environment
and you like
your bathroom visits to be challenging
terribly
builds characters like dustin not like
the most fake factory person
working toilets
walking around in shoes that he
knowingly
knowingly we're making him bleed because
ah
well that we did talk about here at one
point because i didn't come up
i did remember the slew of comments
about my bloody songs
like a functional toilet seat cover and
so
a guy or a girl would go in there and
touch it and it would immediately fall
off and it's like oh and it's just a
it's a bathroom linoleum floor so it's
like
oh [ __ ]
you were going for a ride because it was
not going to stay in place
so for about about three months i've i
had this toilet
i went to target and i was like no i
can't we have to pause because it is
just so [ __ ] funny how true
where like someone like we'd be
in a conversation or a meeting and it's
like two hours
drinking coffee or drinking bourbon and
so then invariably it's like i gotta
take a piss
and it's like yeah yeah in the back and
so i'm just sitting here i start looking
at my email or whatever
and then i just hear like this door shut
and then this muffled the
[ __ ] and it just every time it
killed me so i was like at some point of
your personality i've not encountered
before
no i feel like it makes him make more
sense as a human
it's it it was so funny every time
you know if it's like god and of course
then troy would
like everything out of it it would be a
performance
pledging pledging to all of the gods new
and old
i swear before the sun sets
you will have another toilet seat and
finally i would like
petition angela's like please like i he
i've given up on him you at least could
please do something about nope
and she's like i cannot control him i
was like i understand so
that's your accent
so terrible so finally i showed up
[Laughter]
he like opened the door one time and i
was like i'm
today is my favorite day ever it's it's
like today's like why
and i had just held it up still shrink
wrapped
the white round elongated
you got like this toilet that was built
in like back when there was like a
plunger for it from the top
it's the kind of toilet that you would
expect like
somebody left al pacino a gun for and
he's going to go
and meet with you know [ __ ] barzini
and do them in fairness just so that
it's clear to everyone this is a
commercial space that my studio is not
at home so i inherited
i inherited a a very like small
office space kind of how many years
between you moving in and troy providing
the new toilet seat
how much time years how much time yes
well it wasn't broken the entire
the entire it broke it was in need of
previous inheritance
ladies and gentlemen of the court austin
was saying that he inherited this word
you're saying now your story's changed a
little bit your story now is that the
toilet seat broke after you moved there
oh yeah i've been here over eight years
right uh
and uh don't know which of your guests
broke it
was it troy and he's been feeling guilty
and this was his way
making it up to you that's actually a
good question i have no memory of when
it broke
i just know that it just shifted into a
state of brokenness and i just life
moved on there was
four
the best part was the purgatory of troy
having replaced it but then it ended up
in pam's car
and every time he thought of it she
would be out of the house and he
couldn't get it and so
it was purchased but inaccessible for a
period of like weeks
and even she like forgot for the longest
time first of all kudos to her because i
said when you go to target do me a favor
i need you to pick up a round toilet
seat cover she's like why is it don't
ask questions
and she just did it that's that's that
right there is love
so she did it and then she forgot about
it she said get this [ __ ] toilet seat
cover out of my car i was like i need to
get out of there and then
something weird would happen i would to
be clear i think that i am
closer on this spectrum to the austin
than i am
to the troy what do you mean i will
tolerate
things for a long time because i don't
care i'll be like
it's broken whatever and i just don't
care about it like right now i have uh
my coffee table absolutely sucks so i
bought a new one
and i have that sitting in a box in my
apartment and i have for
six months the issue is that i have to
have this box here because the coffee
table i have already built is too
heavy for me by myself to get out of my
apartment
and during covid there is no way for me
to do it so i'm just living with this
shitty broken coffee table and this box
with this other one in it and just like
i'll figure it out eventually but it is
it is you're saving i mean look
that's what i think also also still not
a toilet
exactly in our defense eventually the
sun will expand
it can be in our done
eventually the sun will expand and
consume the earth and none of this will
matter
exactly is it was it that was it that
you just didn't care you were just like
a minor in comedians because i think
that's how i am about a lot of things
like that i'm like
whatever no i mean but due to troy's
point i
that one did at some point it did become
too hilarious to do anything about
and then uh but then i'll have you know
one time
we were having a meeting for the for the
musical for chorus and that was the
tipping point as i realized okay
you know david gator and liam messler
these
you know ellie everyone's gonna be at
the studio in mass laura bailey's coming
over we're gonna
laura bailey was probably the typical is
like look you can do it to all these
people don't do that to laura bailey
how dare you disrespect the queen that
is laura bailey no yeah
that's probably accurate so i did i did
part of it was that the screws were all
like broken and had to be kind of
you know they were like they snapped off
and so it's like when you
pull a tick out and the head stays in
behind like it was it needed actual
repair
so we repair it troy troy used to come
over and the first thing you would do is
check the bathroom to see and then be
like god damn it
and so i set up a hidden camera
uh that's right when he came over
i set up a hidden camera not in the
bathroom i set up a hidden camera in the
hallway
to witness his reaction to the discovery
of the fixed toilet and of course he
walked right in and goes straight past
it and i was like hey everybody
not for a while what a [ __ ] nothing
do you need to do you need to go to the
bathroom i'm like no
i'm good i'm and i'm also in this coffee
down your throat
amazing uh well we're now 15 minutes in
and i did try to intro the show but
technically failed so hi everyone
welcome to this week's episode of play
watch listen
this is the case for me calling it
toilets and stuff i'm unsure uh i'm a
lot of peace i'm joined by
joined by troy baker mike bithell and
austin wintery
and i feel like we need a big old
disclaimer what
we do need to disclaimer don't ever go
to the bathroom at austin's austin do
you work at sony
do you work at sony kind of austin alana
does yeah so
for anyone who missed the announcement i
announced this week that i am now
working at sony santa monica
studio and just to point out nobody
missed the announcement by the way
it was it was one of the largest things
to happen on twitter i don't think
anybody
i don't know how that happened it was
very weird to see my own name trending
uh very strange did you did you freak
out a little bit you're like why am i
trending
was there a party what did i do wrong
have i been cancelled oh my god it was
bound to happen eventually no it was
very strange
um but very exciting yeah obviously it
just means that um anytime that we talk
about anything that is
i guess any kind of first party related
i just have to give you the
disclaimer for ftc reasons that i am
paid by sony because i can't
be perceived as endorsing something
without
legally telling you that i am an
employee the federal trade commission
yeah i'm a contractor uh i got
none of that [ __ ] going on um i would
very very like a piece of wood
very much like this i got a ps5
exactly in my department i'll get you
all ps5's no
worries i need a ps5 sort me out lana
hook me up yeah i got you
100 in control of all and a dev kit
that's what i actually could be useful
yes they're easier to get right now dev
kits than actual retail consoles they
probably are
they really are they really are yeah i
feel like i have friends in australia
who have dev kits
that don't have ps5 they don't even work
in the game
i need to explain to you audience you
cannot play retail games on dev kits
so there's these weird situations
sometimes where you have a dev kit
but you can't actually play the games
that come out for that console yeah and
i've been here
interesting
could you play a build of the game yes
and to be fair i'm wrong for some
some console variants can play retail
games but you
usually know usually not you can play a
build if you can get built from like the
developer what used to exist
was the best thing ever which was devnet
which was on xbox 360. you could play
basically you had like xbox live arcade
but it was everyone's
dev builds of every game so you could
that sounds like a
horrible security nightmare amazing well
because you're sure
so like so was napster by the way
but you spend like i'd spend like my
lunch times like playing like half inch
i remember that's how i played a lot of
the telltale games
like the early telltale games was like
me playing them on my xbox like
with debug menus like playing their dev
builds
because there's basically i never played
on an xbox live
yeah i only played those games on ipad
really and they were always weird they
were like why that's how i first played
them too actually it was on ipad was
one of my first like actual um
gripping narrative mobile experiences i
think yeah
i feel like i played like one of them on
there and the performance was terrible
so i just
went back to congress they are
definitely better on console
when we i think ironically enough i
think it was batman as well i think it
was that bad
in some cases you were not wrong when we
do um
the in the in the before times where
concerts were a thing and we do
um what is this concert i know exactly
um uh journey live uh
we play on a ps3
uh dev kit um
and still and um
because we had sony actually
uh the the porting house who i'm i'm
blanking the name
of the of the studio um uh
shamefully but the folks that the folks
that
you changed i'll say you've forgotten
the people that put you there
brutal that one was loaded in the
chamber and ready
but it's also extra good because if
anyone doesn't know that game company
does sound like also a made up company
name
it's true good stuff yeah why are they
laughing at this i don't get this
podcast
isn't this game's maybe it's actually
maybe it's who did the ps4
port now that i think of it and it's a
ps4 dev kit but either way someone who
did a port of the game
uh because there were a few ports uh
that happened along the way but the
i guess it would have been the ps4
report they did um
they they made us a special build that
had all the music removed
so all because there's no menu there's
no ui that to do that
like a lot of games have and so we to do
our concert where all the music is live
on stage we need a special one-off build
but we also the result of which to
mike's point
that it's a non-commercial copy of the
game we
still we made a journey live playstation
network
account and we have to manually
whitelist that account before every
concert
um in order to still be able to connect
to other players online so that they can
play
with us in journey while we do the show
um
and um which is as a side note it's
always
it's always hilarious when you know
you're in the show especially a really
good performance where like everyone's
on point
and the audience is just there for it
and the game
ends and it's like this hopefully very
moving experience and there's just that
silence in the room
and then at the very end of the end
credits and it says companions met along
the way and they're all named like
you know [ __ ] dildo yeah exactly
yeah it's a perfect segue into post show
but
austin i know you've done that show a
number of times do you still
i don't even know how to phrase the
question do you still
you know if you are having one of those
great shows where the audience is is
reacting and everything is
uh has gone according to plan do you
still have an emotional reaction to it
or is it just the same thing that you've
done over and over again
well i've always journey was one of
those things that i've never been able
to react the way
normal players have just by virtue of
having worked on it you know i mean
that's that's a familiar
thing i think to all of us uh it's just
like you you fundamentally can't get out
from your inside out perspective
someone yesterday was like oh alana this
is obama because it means that you will
have santa monica studios games spoiled
for you
i was like [ __ ] that's true this is true
oh no you've not experienced that though
yeah have you the kind of the the whole
being a part of the development cycle
and therefore
not ever being able to enjoy the things
you make it's like some kind of weird
like
pact you make with the devil like you
can make any game you want exist but you
can never
truly enjoy it it's kind of dark yeah
but good luck i
disagree with that yeah i
i i i i absolutely push against that
because
it's the same thing as like well now
that you've made a tv show now that
you've made a film
you can't enjoy it it's like no because
it's not it's
especially a game is so much larger than
my own perspective
and especially as an actor far larger
than my
contribution to it so for me
the the joy is always that's what that
looked like
for you it's a little bit different
because you're so intimately involved
and aware that's the difference yeah for
me it's it's like
i had no idea that that's what that was
going to look like i had no idea that
that's the way
shadow of war was a little bit different
for me because like i was
more involved in that game uh from both
i i didn't have any say so obviously
over the design or the writing
but for understanding how these
performances needed to be and how these
scenes were going to shape out i had to
know things
ahead of time so the big narrative
moments
i was still surprised sometimes i was
like
wait a minute that's not that's not the
shot that i chose
which is a whole other lesson uh
learning how to let go
of your your version of it i
i had my version of that it's very
specific to acting
in a way though no it's specific to
directing like joss whedon was the one
who was like
my job is to direct he said do you ever
have any problems with
you know fighting with editors he goes
no it's not my job my job is to direct
that movie
and then once it moves down the vine to
the next person's job that's their job
and i let them do their job
and so the the notion of the auteur like
mike and i have always talked about
where it's just like that's not that's
not really doing it all yourself is not
that impressive anymore
being able to replicate your vision and
your
perspective and being able to work
alongside somebody something like steven
spielberg which it's like
i direct directors and i really
replicate myself in that team to me is
far
more impressive like that's leadership
so that's that's what i
i learned that the hard way i i walked
onto the set of shadow of war
thinking that i had to know everything
about directing and i i bossed people
around like i tried to rule that stage
and by the end of it that's where they
come from security right you just kind
of
absolutely yeah that's the whole place
that it comes from is i didn't feel like
i had
i had to prove myself because i was
afraid that i couldn't do the gig
and by the end of it i was like no if
you want to ask a question about that
you need to go that guy
he's going to perfect i love that shot i
trust you're it it's so much more
rooted in trust than it is in pride
and it's just a far better way to work
with people i just learned
like i approach everything and i'm sure
we spoke about before by asking like
loads of questions and not being ashamed
of asking questions and i don't think
that's ever been
received poorly i don't think anyone's
ever been like you asked too many
questions you're not supposed to be
learning everyone has always been like
a great question yeah
no it would actually it would be a red
flag if someone
just acted like i know everything i got
this i got
i got nothing to learn like if someone's
just sit sitting there
stewing in their own glory uh massive
uh massive uh issues you can do that
maybe a little bit with hosting stuff
sometimes
in that like you know if i have like a
two-hour tech rehearsal and i'm like
we know how to do this we're gonna be
we're gonna be fine
like that one i can i wouldn't say it's
basking in my own glory but it's more of
a like i've done this so many times
to the this exact thing and i get that
you need me to be here to
reassure you but this is going to be
perfect to the extent that sometimes i'm
like does this need to
okay okay we need a tech rehearsal um
that that is definitely a thing but i
feel like with anything where you're
directing people or working with teams
in a different way to just like
let me speak on camera is a is a whole
other ball game
but it is like you say it's as much
about reassuring other people as
anything like i've had it before where
yeah i remember when i've hired like
very junior people who's like their
first game or whatever
and they'll ask questions that like more
seasoned experienced developers will
definitely like
know well you don't need to worry about
that at all that will just work itself
out kind of questions
and definitely like very early on when i
was first working like as a director
with very junior people
i was i was less i was more dismissive
than i could have been in those
of those early conversations where i was
like don't worry about it it's going to
be fine like
and i thought that was enough but
actually what i realized like i went on
was
no taking five minutes now to like
explain to them why it's going to be
fine and
and answer their question actually saves
like weeks of them being worried about
something because
because it's the problem with um like
when you're a junior you don't you can't
necessarily tell if the people you're
working for and with
are competent or not or not so you can
kind of
you can fall into a trap of not knowing
whether the person you're talking to is
in a hurry or stupid and the easiest way
to
avoid that problem is to explain explain
yourself basically so yeah
well that that a lesson i learned i have
a question then
for our illustrious host
you are not a you are a seasoned writer
you are someone who has written short
stories novels op-eds editorials odd
articles
all sorts of stuff operas operas several
yeah
four at least yeah um every episode of
this podcast
every episode of this podcast that's the
brilliance of it by the way like that
line that we're just
really good actors not just troy
[Laughter]
what was it like for you walking in
that first day when you got the gig
and was there a feeling of yours that
that
did you were you able to maintain that
thing of just just ask questions and
just submit yourself to the humility the
process or did you
did you struggle with that imposter
syndrome or are they going to find
no not even a tiny bit so like i've had
people be like hope you don't get
imposter syndrome and i'm like i don't
hey it's half that i've worked very hard
to
you know set myself up to be where i am
so i don't think that i have any of that
kind of impostor syndrome
but um i am a junior writer uh i don't
have
any issues with being open about needing
to learn things even in the slightest
because i like
learning so much so that's always gonna
be a thing where i'm like i don't know
how to do this teach me how to do this
please
it would be very stupid for me to walk
into santa monica studios and be like
i'm here to tell you how to write as a
critic and i'm sure that they
picked up that i'm not that kind of
person in the interview process which is
part of it so
definitely not a problem for me at all
what are you most excited about like
what what
facet of being a writer are you most
excited about
working on or learning about or being
able to
expand upon that you currently have like
what are you like
what excites you the most when you say
teach me something you're like what do i
really want to learn so i want to learn
this
can you nail that down feel like i can
nail that down no
um i guess when it comes to video game
writing specifically if i were to give
you like a top level question of
sorry answer of like what am i excited
to learn
i think uh how iterative the process is
is something that i've always been told
about
but something that i am very interested
to see in person
is like like for anything for
for an item description how many times
does something like that potentially get
rewritten and how many times doesn't it
and i think that kind of stuff is stuff
that i just
you know having never seen it i'm very
interested to to learn about
um because i've had friends who work in
triple a write games and be like hey
everything that i worked on for the last
six months just got completely scrapped
and we have to start over
and that's a thing that i've never had
to deal with is having something
bent that i worked really hard on i've
certainly had you know the
um my assassin's creed origins review
was originally like 10 000 words and
obviously we had to cut that down so i'm
like i'm fine with killing my darlings
that's something that i definitely learn
in university as well as like uh you
have to get rid of this stuff
but i have not had anything that i've
worked on just completely be scrapped
and
especially when you're working really
hard on it i feel like that's that's a
very bizarre adjustment period that i
know
people who've worked in triple a writing
have a really tough time with
there's a the austin and i were talking
about this the other day
what do you think of the notion of yeah
taking it back yeah
[Laughter]
they a friend of mine who's a writer and
also
uh he's he's one of the go-to people
that punches up scripts
for films um and because of that he's
probably written more he's definitely
written more movies than he's ever been
given credit for
um and he's also worked in games
and i asked him one time about a project
he said um
i was like how do you we're talking
about writing with your heart he goes
they get my skill and they get my
experience but they don't get my heart
and so austin and i were having this
conversation about
hey what do you think of that notion and
b what gets your heart and do you
believe that
you have to give your heart into your
job or is there a level
of huh i think i want to
either be good at not but even if like
what comes with that like let's say you
six months
you devoted to building this character
up riding this world
their entire arc everything you you got
to know them they're a real person and
they just pop your head
pop their head in your door one day and
go oh by the way scrap that character
but we need you to now completely
rebuild in
this world and rewrite this character
and do all of this from the ground up
is there a level of of diminishing
return is there some kind of emotional
attrition
that is attached if that's the fourth
time that that's happened the fifth time
or is it like that's the gig i think
that's probably a thing that yeah like i
said people in
aaa game writing probably have to deal
with i mean mike i feel like you could
speak more to that where i don't think i
have had to i think that i
so like i i don't know if you guys saw i
recently put together an accessibility
award show
that was i had spoken about that on the
on the show before your trophies in it i
don't know if you saw
um i didn't get a chance to watch but
congrats on that thank you
i loved your sentiment that you shared
at some point in the
in the wake of the nuclear blast which
was your announcement
saying like just go do the thing
um well yeah so the reality of that show
was it was a thing that i
i created pitched last year
um to an entirely separate team of
people and my attitude being this is
something that i think that we need to
do
uh from the perspective of i think an
award show is a very good way to make
more developers aware of these things
um to try to to push that further in the
medium
so i pitched it a full year ago um yeah
with was not in partnership with
ablegamers at that point in time
and then covet happened and everyone
dropped out everyone uh which you know i
always knew that i would be
epi'ing and writing and and hosting it
because that seemed like the easiest way
to do it i always knew that i would have
to do all of that but
i couldn't do it without any support um
so it became really hard and i was like
this show is just it's just done we'll
just have to bank it for next year
and then the last was part two came out
and it has more accessibility options
than any other video game ever made
um and i had this moment of of watching
some of the disabled community talking
about how incredible that was for them
there was this video of this one girl
who was crying because she was able to
play the game and it was just like this
thing where i was like
just because this show got a lot harder
doesn't mean
i shouldn't do it so yes it got really
[ __ ] difficult
um but i can still make it happen just
not necessarily in the way that i wanted
that's not a good enough excuse so
that's when i was like okay this team of
people can't work with me
very good friends with steve spahn so i
went to him i pitched it to him and i
was like i will do all of this
all the ep'ing i fully funded the show
that was all my money
um alana pierre's sponsor of uh the
video game accessibility awards
and i was like i need your help with
giving me categories because i can't do
that by myself and also with getting
uh an actual player base of disabled
gamers who can do the voting for us
because i didn't want to have anything
to do with any of the awards
processes themselves or any of the
nominees so it was still really hard
like that show was very difficult um
and part of what made it a little bit
easier is if that like i know
that i can executive produce something
and host it then i'm like then i don't
have to worry about anyone else doing it
which meant it was an absurd amount of
work but
my point there was i still just did the
thing
even if the thing was not the thing that
we envisioned we envisioned a
we did have sponsors it was going to be
a pax live award show where we're going
to fly people in and
have proper awards and like right now
i'm dealing with uh all of our
certificates for winners being late
which means that i'm gonna have to
probably mail those out next week and
it's just like that's the reality of
covert and it's a bummer but
i i am very proud that we still put it
together and and
steve spawn and ablegamers did such a
phenomenal job of also being really
careful with messaging and and
sensitivities of stuff that i was just
not aware of but i think that's a mantra
that i've had pretty much my whole life
which is how
any of my career has really occurred hey
a massive benefit that i know a lot of
people don't have that i do have is that
i know exactly what i want all the time
and i know a lot of people don't
function that way but i'm like this is
what i want to do
so here's the things that i think that i
need to do to do that so i'm going to do
that
um and i know that's not inherent for
everyone but for all content creation
and we've said this on the show before
like i know i think
troy i feel like you spoke about this
recently it's like just start doing it
if you want to do anything just
do it and it doesn't have to be perfect
you can fail the first time
it's better than not doing it at all 20
games in you know it's fine
yeah this is bad games mike biffle one
day you'll have it
in one day oh
but i think that's honestly like
genuinely i think that's the big one for
me is just
in terms of getting stuff cancelled and
i've definitely like there are
we joke occasionally about like putting
out like a book of all of the games that
we've tried to get made in the last 10
years that just got
fallen through and and there's some
really good
little ideas in there and stuff but like
the thing for me is always trying to
focus on the experience of the
production
rather than the outcome so yes you gave
six months to writing something that got
canned but you got six months of
experience you got six months of
learning
and the thing has came up with austin's
example the other day about you know his
computer crashing and losing work
the thing you make after those six
months will be better than the thing you
would have made yeah
six months previous so there has been an
achievement doesn't mean that it's not
annoying as hell when someone
you know destroys your work but at the
same time like yeah i think
i got a lot happier as a creator when i
stopped worrying about
the outcomes of the work and just
started enjoying the work
and tried to make that the focus my
games got turned as well as a result
i will try to keep that in mind that is
a really that's a very enlightening
refreshing and inspiring perspective
because that the onus that is upon the
person
the only way that works is if i'm doing
something that i truly love doing
because if the whole gig is not the
outcome
then that means i have to love what i'm
doing because if i hate what i'm doing
but the
outcome is is worth it then i can i can
mitigate that you know fairly easily
it's like i'm making a shitload of money
or this is going to give me likes or
whatever so i don't want to do this but
if that's not the point if the point is
the process
this better be something like the
process than you do on looking at the
likes though don't you that's the thing
i think i've
learned is that if you're not enjoying
the thing you're doing to earn the
money the praise or whatever then why
are you
you're just wasting that's a massive one
in content creation
um is the amount of people who come to
me and say
how do i build a following the answer is
always
you don't try uh you just make content
you like and you are yourself
uh that's how you build the following uh
you i i never had any kind of goal of i
want this amount of
of social media ever have i thought
about that it's always just been
be genuine be myself on twitter
that's the great dream trend on twitter
in california and that was actually the
goal was not that i wanted to write
a triple a video game it was that i
wanted to figure out how to get my
career to a point
[Laughter]
yeah i have to do the whole two weeks of
not telling people where i was going and
like
making sure it was sony so all the
people have been calling me an xbox get
really confused
excitement yeah that's great exactly
that was actually really really cool
i i actually really love this era in
gaming right now because the fact that
like
phil spencer like reached out and was
like congratulations
i feel like there's this whole i wish
that politics were as
uh reach across the aisle as gaming
platforms are
you know what i mean like that would be
the stakes i wish that were true
stakes are a little lower in games
though a little lower i mean
that's true almost as much money in it
though
yeah yeah
um yeah oh yeah um just to no sorry go
ahead
no austin yeah you go ahead i disagree
go ahead i like how i like how troy
jumped in there
on alana's behalf though to be like no
austin please
um the uh when you're ready mate please
go for it
seriously go ahead awesome the whole
thing
go ahead seriously please nugget one
about your muted being the sort of we
can't hear you austin you're all here
[ __ ]
i could manually beat you for the joke
but i don't sorry austin go ahead wait
are you actually [ __ ] with me sorry
what was that [ __ ]
this is because of this is because of
the [ __ ] toilet seat
my coffee is empty so i can't even have
like
i can't even have like a a
reconciliation like commiseration coffee
please i don't even know what's going on
anymore
i'm suddenly like in that mode or i'm
looking around going like am i wearing
like you feel you feel high right now
don't you because yeah exactly
everyone else feel like one way or
another everyone else being real weird
right now man
oh gosh
at least at least at least to zoom's
credit when you mute me and i talk
it flashes on screen you know you're
muted right now
and so i was like yeah that one that one
you didn't get past me
oh you're muted i didn't want to to be
fair
please go ahead you didn't want to um
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i was
gonna say i know we derailed you pretty
hard there what were we talking about it
was
crazy
exactly yeah that was draft the final
draft of
the sopranos in action um no
well oh i know what it was it was about
the whole like can you give your heart
can you can you is it worth that uh
because yeah for me absolutely i
i don't know how not to like there are
jobs even just
in demoing and you know like auditioning
the composer version of auditioning
to get jobs like there are some there
are some out there that i have swung
so hard to get and then didn't
and it still bothers me and not that i
resent
them for finding something else like
they
they they someone else they that's cool
like that's their job
i did my role they did theirs and all
props to the person who did but i i
invested so much in like
dreaming about the raw clay of their
thing and what i could do with it and
just got so excited
and not never mind the times that it's
like you're hiring orchestras and just
going all in
on that pitch and investing enormous
amounts
of time and money and all that i always
forget that that you sometimes to pitch
have to spend money
my auditions what i can't boo-hoo about
an audition or a meeting that didn't go
well austin was like cool i spent
five grand in six months you know
and i didn't get the gig i'm like god
it's so much easier
even as a writer you could do a writing
sample you're like ah
that wasn't that bad
you can't get caught up on rejection and
you're the better for it like and
and are you am i
yeah i'm a better composer if nothing
else and you know plus especially then
just purely practically those times
where i went into the studio hired an
orchestra
every time you step up at bat in that
particular
world that's that's you're acquiring
mileage that is hard to come by so like
you just don't get to stand in front of
an orchestra every day so even if i'm
buying my way into it occasionally
as a byproduct of a demo like that's
still time with my engineer with
musicians like
that's that's invaluable experience
that's worth it just because
you know you don't get that every day
it's it's yeah so
future ilana jumping in with another
note here before this conversation
starts
just for the record because optically
it's a little bit strange now this
was recorded before the game awards
nominees were announced
um thus i did not know that i was going
to be nominated for the content creator
award
leading into this conversation but i
stand by everything that i said okay bye
but i ha but to your point though the
the thing i i realized something else i
was gonna bring up is there's an actor
friend of mine
this guy j august richards who
um was he was a gun on angel if you ever
watched angel
but he was also he played death lock in
agents of shield
um amazing guy we've been friends for
almost 15 years now and he's one of
these
super like he's very he's very
um very philosophical and like
and thoughtful and always kind of
checking himself you're describing troy
but i remember i remember one time he
and i talking and
this was early on before i had really
learned a lot of the the lessons that i
wouldn't be able to survive without but
kind of apropos we're talking about
i remember him saying you know he was
like you know how many
emmy-winning tv actors i know that are
[ __ ] miserable
or oscar-winning directors that are
[ __ ] miserable he's like when you
when you place your dreams on the prize
or on
on any tangible point on the map instead
of it being about the road
yeah man you're just no amount no
amounts ever going to be satisfied no
matter what it is
and i remember chasing awards is is
something that i think is almost like
chasing achievements like it's a thing
that you could do
and i say this is someone who's never
done it but it's a thing that you could
do um
to like add like add an extra bar but i
think if that is your goal
is i want to be an award-winning
whatever what does that mean to you as a
human
i i know that feeling
um
i chased that because i wanted that
validation
and the moment that i
wanted that validation was it started in
the scene
that i felt was going to get me that
award
that was going to get me that validation
and i chased that feeling all the way
down to the finish line
until i was sitting in the audience
in london at the baftas
and i didn't get it and i didn't realize
in that moment
how badly i wanted that and how
desperately i was clutching after that
prize
until the award show is over
the champagne reception is over
the after party is over and i'm back in
my hotel room
and i am empty
and your boy had himself a good cry
and i had a comment i remember looking
at i remember exactly where i was
i remember the layout of the room and
everything and i literally had that
um cliche pose
of hands on the sink looking at myself
in the mirror
and i looked at myself and i said it
can't be about this
it can't be about this it doesn't
change your work and the truth is
ashley deserved it and if that means
that somebody loses
so be it because that's the truth it
doesn't change the work that you do
and that was a tough lesson for me to
learn but it was in that moment
that i resigned myself to the fact that
i will never
ever ever again the the entity that that
can bring
and and the the collusion that i can
bring between
or occlusion between friendships is like
it can't be this man
don't chase the awards don't chase the
accolades don't chase the validation
the process the road that is the gig
that's well and how many commitments and
how many
thousands yeah
how many thousands of people probably
even in that moment that you were in
the room feeling sorry for yourself were
thinking
my exposure to the character arc of joel
has made me a better person sure or like
i think differently about life because
of
that like all the things that really
matter were happening in that moment
and that thing made you blind to it
although i do fantasize
that that's something that's how we got
here
my fantasy is that you'll you'll you'll
you'll win a bafta
and then some young actor will come up
to you like maybe someone who you
beat that night is going to come up to
you and they're going to be a [ __ ]
wreck and you're going to be like
dude i've been on both sides
[Laughter]
it's hard out there i think it's gotta
let it go it really doesn't matter
that was my audition for the role of
young joel
i feared the beard soldier i i think i
think it's an important journey to go
through i think it's i don't think
there's a shame in in being
i think a lot of people have grown on an
emotional level by not winning of after
over the years
i think that's i think that's probably
the origin story
like genuinely i'm not taking the piss
out of you i think that's i think that's
a
important step to go through i think
that's a that's a that's something that
makes sense
and the great thing of course is it
doesn't actually matter like
because later i still i whenever i do
anything with bafta
i still on the blurb it says the bafta
winning
game developer my bitter i've never one
of after people just think i did
and it's what yeah that's some mandela
effect [ __ ]
what are you talking about what about
them have
like if someone said to me has troy won
a bafta i put money out people just
assume that if you've had a career long
enough and they've heard some of your
stuff you would have a woman
kyle i'll just give you one if you're
nolan north they just give you one
like but my point is that to me that
illustrates just how kind of
it's wonderful and it's great but though
the job of awards
to my mind is more to elevate people who
who aren't finding the audience
elsewhere or or
whoever start their careers like people
yeah it's one of those ones where people
just assume eventually just people just
assume you have lots of awards i don't
think i've won more than like two or
three awards in my career but people
just assume
that thomas was alone won everything
thomas was alone has a 74 meter critic
you know it doesn't matter none of it i
said i need to double check
i love that thomas was alone it's my
favorite thing about thomas's loan every
time we re-release thomas was a loan on
a new platform
the metacritic goes up by five because
people remember
it being a better game than it was
it's like a crude acclaim and what's
interesting is you see that with every
single game we've done
it's a really again a very humbling
thing of realizing oh this
is kind of nonsense in a way you know
this is it's okay i got that [ __ ] on
twitch man or sorry on
on the switch get drive it on twitch
this is the guy that was yelling for
cars to slow down by the way
it is coming it is coming to okay no
thomas was lying apologies as a 77
meters like okay sorry i thought
i think it was lower before but still
not like you know people assume higher
it's but that's my point is all of this
is if you fixate on this stuff then yeah
you're missing your
life you know it's the work that's fun
and there's some small [ __ ] there
put it wrong there's still days you
don't enjoy your job obviously but like
on the whole you should be trying but
you still would rather even those days
you're still you you wouldn't trade it
oh i've had real dreams
i'm not going back i'm not going back to
a real job you can't make me
i feel like i in a lot of ways um i'm a
person who lives without credit
um in that i don't get credited for
anything that i do so like even major
publications for this
the the video game accessibility awards
were saying ablegamers um the ablegamers
awards show naughty dog tweeted out
saying thank you ablegamers um
and that's the thing that they generally
seem to have seen
me as host um because
probably because woman who works on
camera um despite being the creator
writer executive producer of the show
however i don't [ __ ] care like i
think my attitude has always been
a you're never going to get credit from
people who don't want to give you credit
there is no point fighting for
validation of people that you don't know
validate yourself
and i know that's very hard to do people
are not that self-assured i know that
that's not very easy to do
but i am much happier to see
a naughty dog tweet out full disclosure
sony employee
tweet out
the charity that that i was trying to
raise money for who
frankly did do a lot of work and i
couldn't have done it without them um
than to credit me in any way whatsoever
because what would i get from that other
than
oh uh a hundred more people um think
that uh i hosted it
like that's all they'd think anyway it
just doesn't matter and i think i've had
that attitude
like anyone who works with me closely
will be like i understand what you do
and i understand how hard you work
the the praise from from strangers
is not something that i think is even
feasible for me to chase because i've
definitely come to terms with no matter
what i accomplish in my career it will
never be
of my own merit it will always be
because i'm a woman that's happened with
this new job announcement every step of
the way
it'll always be like well because
because tits or whatever so
it's it's pointless to chase um but also
like never going to fulfill it is the
thing that i think i've seen another
thing but that's
never gonna feel about it that's the
problem is if you go to
if you go to strangers for validation
you also
get you know you also feel attacked when
those same strangers don't like you and
kind of
true yes you can't if you don't want to
play
the chorus you want to play to the the
people around you the people you care
about
or yourself that's okay too
it is i want my mom to be proud of me
but everyone else is like
it is trading in a dead currency and it
is something that it
from that moment forward especially like
2016 forward has been like
this can't be it can't be this what is
it then and the impermanence of identity
that is presupposed on the
whims of others who don't even know who
they are
much less know who you are especially
when there's no real name attached to it
when it is
bungled on 69 when it's just a screen
name
how dare how dare we allow that person
to to dictate who i am what i do what
i'm worth
all of this 69 it is you're absolutely
right
yeah they make you a lot of good points
i mean earlier work
the earlier work before when they were
in any level
i was trying to think of a way that i
could wrap the conversation back into it
um
the episode about toilets um but then i
was like does anyone have any like
video game development related anecdotes
about
toilets that i can in some way make
informative as a fun
perspective
toilets are the best summary of any game
in which they appear
there's a solid game design thesis you
can tell a lot about video game by
what's going on with the toilet is the
toilet interactive brilliant or is it
purely
no no no no there are blogs about this
like in terms of like when you see a
toilet in a video game
more often than not because a toilet
toilet is a common prop it's something
that every video game has
by the way it sounds like you're giving
a david cage
talk right now because david cage 100
believes in this
but it's true so every every game has a
toilet in it
and every game that toilet is going to
represent there are blogs about this
there are people there are twitter
accounts like
they're they're every a toilet is going
to represent the game it's in so is that
so if you play duke nukem
the toilet's gonna have a turd floating
in it and you can pick it up and throw
it because that's duke nukem
if i'm if there's a toilet in um
it's gonna irradiate you but might have
some blood
right if you play like a a beautiful aaa
cinematic third-person action game
uh you're gonna walk in the toilet it's
gonna be the most beautiful toilet ever
but you're not gonna be able to interact
with it and you're not gonna be able to
get within six feet of it because it's
gonna be an invisible barrier this is
this is blowing my mind right now i feel
like we're high are you serious right
now
yeah i think it makes perfect it is a
toilet if you if you needed
um like an atomic value for video game
design like a baseline
um uh a calibration tool for
what is the design and aesthetic ethos
of a game development team
then you would need something that
appears in all games is irrelevant to
core gameplay mechanics
that you could look at and go how does
this object
uh what does this tell us what how has
this team approached this problem of
having this object in their world
and a toilet is in every video game so a
toilet tells you you know what would
have been
you know what would have been the
perfect proof of this which i don't
think is actually true
but you know how some toilets especially
especially in europe have like
the two different volume uh flush
yeah i have that in my house yeah it's
not it's like
you're telling your appearance i also
of course you do if if if that had been
uh a feature of the toilets in deus ex
that would have been the perfect like
you do
do do it your way but when you know that
i would have felt like sex that attracts
an enemy right or something
like hitman you can flood bathrooms i
think you do it with the sinks rather
than the toilet so it doesn't fully
track but that's why i i just texted
rising i think the toilets are uh what i
know one of them at least is a fast
travel location which you have to have
in that game because
the way that the timer works in that
game that's funny
i think he's honestly oh my god okay
hold on hold on
i wanted to see if you're doing [ __ ]
i just i just texted neil
and i said what do you think about
toilets and their role in video game
design
and he says very important love them in
duke nukem 3d
wow now
all this tells us is that me and neil
druckmann are exactly
as pretentious as each other that's all
this tells us oh
my god no i get it i fully understand
what you're saying
like i feel like if i think of a video
game and then i think of the toilet the
toilet is representative of the video
game again i feel like fallout's a
really good example if you drink from it
you'll be irradiated
but sometimes toilets also have loot in
them that's fallout
nobody's also that also might be true
here at my studio by the way yeah yeah
good point
your view towards your guests right like
it's like i feel like resident evil
there's often uh there's often someone
hiding in the toilet there's a zombie
hiding in the toilet that's
that is totally a thing this is not
bravo for bringing it home i think you
guys got me high
all right it's still a dream i was gonna
say the thing i always pay attention to
is stairs when it comes to game design
is how if how a character's feet always
i'm like how do they look walking
upstairs though because i understand
it's extremely difficult to do and there
are very few games where it looks like
the character takes the individual steps
the other premonition does it quite well
i always noticed when they first
we started to pivot towards ragdoll
physics
in like npcs and you would have a
character where they would die
at the top of the stairs but still
register as being at the top so there
would be this
stiff cardboard thing extending out into
space and then eventually learning
to actually cater to the shape of it i
thought this is progress
i i really appreciate a good realistic
death fall down a staircase
that's got to be hard to do also hair
hair physics
but toilet's number one as we have
decided on this
the toilet on this the toilet episode
flush watch listen watch flashy flourish
all right we'll see you next time bye
[Laughter]